après bien fou malade à l'arrière ça va
moyen de la commission des gens ne me
cause ou à bas taux tu déconnes je crois
que tu as une fâcheuse tendance à perdre
un petit peu trop froid dans les moments
difficiles
tout ce qui avait été prévu et tout ce
qui n'était pas envisageable à la
lecture c'est à dire la surprise est ce
que ça va être a réussi ou pas réussi 20
les effets spéciaux de ce film s'ils
sont tous de ce genre là on peut dire
qu'on a déjà offert au public un grand
spectacle populaire maintenant en
comédie j'ai le souvenir d'un couple qui
s'entend à merveille parce que benoît je
laime profondément problème déjà leur
sexe et caractère entier c'est l'acteur
studio il fait pas les choses à moitié
les parkas et to buy toi tu ouvres nous
là on est où là
entre bacall et touba entre michael et
tout va entre bach allait tout bas mais
oui les plus bas de bach out ou pas on
est plus probable chez nous tout bas
novell bakel tout va tif tiff gif tiff
qui ne peut pas on est en train de le
faire en dix ans font que ça fonctionne
il faut que le rire mais mattel endroit
il faudra compte par la phrase par l'
ipo une réaction non non il faut le
jouer
top ça t'amuse de le faire puisqu'on
regus a maintenant je veux faire ma
gueule
ça